I am still blown out that that movie
came out a star as born I mean you had
two hit [__] songs I mean genuine
hits off of that movie and I said to you
dude go out on tour first of all it
wasn't my voice it was the characters
the way he sings and um explain that to
me in other words you keep saying that
that guy Jackson Maine sang with that
voice you know I mean if I me were going
to sing like remember I remember Billy
Joel talking about he always could
imitate so many people's voices and his
singing voice was a a bunch of Patchwork
of all these different voices that's
kind of what with Jackson Maine is so if
I were going to start singing as like a
whole first of all you can't for me it's
like that would be a whole lifetime
thing I mean it took me a year Howard of
training with this guy Roger love I
think we did it three or four times a
week just so I could get up and sing in
front of people because it it's so hard
I found it because of breathing so and
it wasn't it's not something deep inside
me like Maestro I spent six years on it
cuz I'm absolutely obsessed with
conducting I was not obsessed with
singing I was obsessed with being a like
that I could play a rockar potentially
like everything that that sort of meant
you could have Bradley maybe dubbed in a
voice but that would have sucked right
the nuclear power of the movie is Lady
Gaga's voice I that has to be recorded
live and so we recorded all the vocals
live and then so I had to learn how to
sing otherwise I mean because you know
Theo story of the movie happens when
they're on stage singing I mean it would
have been a joke first of all I would
have felt like such an idiot dude I was
opening my crazy and it would have
looked bogus it would have been crazy
and I thought that my voice was good
enough that I believe it as long as I
believed it I'm like no I believe it I
believe that guy was real did you have
any idea when you were recording these
things for the movie did you have any
inkling that man these might be on the
radio and become huge hits I didn't
think that but but I did think we were
very judicious about like making sure we
were we were we worked on tons of songs
you know uh Lucas Nelson uh David Cobb
all these great musicians writers would
were working with us uh Mark Ronson yeah
the bar was like it can't we can't put
anything in the movie that I don't feel
like is a dope you know really Dope song
so I yeah I was in love with the music
you know the only one I was scared of
was the one that I wrote myself black
eyes which I you know like I wrote a
song and arranged it really by itself
but you must have had some idea that you
could sing in other words I don't know
you must have look I thought I mean no I
I mean I sang Gospel Choir I I had I had
a feeling that I was I had good pitch
and that like there was something
interesting about my voice but I know I
would have to do a lot of work but yes I
thought that given a small bandwidth you
know if I could do a guy in a small
bandwidth I it would work and when
you're singing with Lady Gaga do you do
it together in a studio where you both
we were singing on on stage that's we
were record that's what I'm trying to
say we were recording everything live so
what you're seeing we're that's coming
out of our mouth and being recorded by
Steve marrow and the sound crew in
camera that's that's the whole point so
when you see like my veins or her veins
and you know people are really singing
[__]
remarkable